Mark: What are you doing there?
Ethan: This was OUR thing
Mark: This was our thing...
Wade: Well
Mark: Alright Imma get- no NO
*Tyler laughing*
Mark: nO
no
Bob: I'm on this camera.  *laughing*
Mark: Hi. I'm Markiplier.
And I'm-- Bob: And I'm the intro?
Mark: Yeah
*incoherent laughter* Bob: Okay I'll be quiet, you go
Mark: Hi, I'm Markiplier, and welcome to the Improv Challenge-
NOPE-
-This is the CHANGE Improv Challenge
*everyone laughing * Mark: I CHANGED IT *warped noise*
Mark (Voiceover): Hiii~, we had some leftover improv scenes that were actually REALLY funny but didn't fit into their own video, so here is a compilation
of those funny scenes-and I'm saying 'funny' alot
But I uh- I mean empty promises are just a bunch of lies
FUCK
It's funny, watch it, enjoy it
Buh-bye, now!  b~ye
Bob: You guys are...uh
Two members of the crew
-Do you know the movie Armageddon?
Mark: Yeah, Ethan: Mm-hm Mark: Yeah
Bob: You're two members of the crew on Armageddon, and you've JUST landed on the asteroid
And you need to get all the gear off the thing and start drilling the hole
To put the nuke in the asteroid
Mark: Right, Ethan: Okay
Mark: Is that the one with Bruce Willis? Ethan: Yeah
Mark: Okay cool
I'm Bruce Willis!
We've GOTTA blow this asteroid up.
Ethan: I'm Steven Tyler's daughter.
Mark: I've always thought you were the HOTTEST girl on this mission...
But let's... not give up yet.
Ethan: I'm YOUR daughter...
(Mark) Right. (Ethan) ...too.
Mark: I stand by my words, don't try to change my mind.
(Ethan) Yes. (Mark) We're about to die, I gotta be honest at least one time in my life.
Let's unload this stuff off of the ship
Bob: CHANGE
Mark: You do that-
Ethan: Let's get- Let's get all these puppies, off the boat
Bob: CHANGE
Ethan: Lets get drillin'!
Bob: Change?
Ethan: I once murdered an entire pod of dolphins.
Mark: You know what?
That asteroid would have done the same.
And frankly-
Ethan: That's what tell myself every night.
Mark: Frankly, since we're gonna die,
I-I figure, you know, we can do whatever the hell we want.
We could kill dolphins.
(Mark): Hey!    (Ethan): We can kill bears.
Mark: We could let this asteroid go and kill EVERYTHING if you wanna.
Ethan: We could kill children and I-
Mark: Whoa!
Bob: CHANGE!
Mark: Yeaaaaaahhhh.
Mark: Huh huh.
Huhwaha.
(Bob): CHANGE! (Mark): Keep the bodies
*GIGGLE*
MMMmmm that's bad! No no no no! Don't do dat!
Well, I mean the entire planet could die, a few kids go here and there, I mean...
*Screechy 'Eh'*
It's not that bad.
In the grand scheme of things.
I mean you can't do a few if the asteroid hits the Earth.
It's gonna kill literally all the children and the people.
Unless you got children stowed away...in the junk drawer.
CHANGE!
Unless you got dead bodies piled up in your pants!
Unless you can find the sausage!
*Wade laughing*
Okay!
NO MY SAUSAGE!
I was saving that for when we blow it!
Why did you instantly start eating my sausage?
It's delicious! It's good space food. It's so much better than that toothpaste and-
I  thought I taught my daughter better than to eat other people's sausages!
God dammit, To- Tanya- Tonya?
Is my name Tonya?
Y'know what? It's all a little hazy up here. I think my suit's running out of oxygen.
We should probably get to work.
We should get drillin'
Yeah we should get drillin'
DOOF-za-za-za-za-za-za-za-za-za-za-za-za
CHANGE!
Uuuuunnnnnnhhhhh
*Laughter*
CHANGE!
*Chainsaw noise?*
Yeah that's a hole!
It's already pre-drilled.
Oh!
So we don't strip the wood.
This is one of those pre-drilled asteroids! Y'know!
God really did us a favor on this one! Alright! Let's put-
He sure did! (Yeah)
Alright. Hang on I forgot-
Let's put the cover on it.
Well, we haven't put the bomb in!
Is that like a safety cover so no one falls in?
Oh! Now you're safety conscious. (That's there for safety.)
Oh. Okay. Alright then.
Well what do I do with this bomb?
Oh we can put it in one of the numerous pre-drilled holes! It doesn't have to the one.
It's a perforated asteroid!
We don't wanna come into the first hole we find and be like 'YEAH THAT'S THE ONE!'
We should probably, y'know, search our options...
Okay.
CHANGE!
Aaaah I don't know about that.
Aaah I've got an itch!
CHANGE!
Aaaahh!
The Earth! It's closin' in!
We gotta pick fast, which hole!
Hey!
Champion... Hole... Filler
I remember back when you were growing up.
You were the greatest hole filler the world has ever seen.
I was.
I said 'My daughter, oh, well she's gonna fill the most important hole.' And I think you should get the honors.
You said 'My daughter, Steven Tyler's daughter.'
Steven Tyler's daughter.
The best hole filler.
The Steven Tyler's daughter.
Alright! I'm gonna fill the hole! I'm gonna do it for you!
A'ight. (Alright)
Hmmm (Squeak) that one's a little small.
That one's a little wide.
It's like throwing a hotdog in a hallway.
CHANGE!
It's like throwing a bear down a ca- *Stifled Laughter* Canyon.
Change?
That one's too big.
*Laughter*
You're right. When you're right, you're right.
This one's just right!
Wow.
Ah, it's like a Goldilocks story here. (Oh, Man)
Woo
Well, since we only got, what like 30 seconds left until we hit the Earth? Maybe we should...
Celebrate?
CHANGE!
Y'know. You have the prettiest ass.
Tonya Harding's daughter...
I love you.
*Laughter*
BOOM!
End scene.
*Laughter*
Chest bump...
Father-daughter chest bump.
You're father-daughter shopping for a prom dress.
Well, I just don't know which one I want.
Dad...What about this one?
Do you think it would show off a little bit too much up here?
Yeah, it's too slutty.
(Wade): It's my favorite one I've seen so far- (Bob): No.
No, no, no. No, no.
There's just not that many options.
What would you go with?
Do any of these dresses go down on the floor anymore?
Let's go to the long dresses. Long dresses...
They cover up the-cover up the top part too
Do they make dresses with sleeves?
(Bob) You find me a sleeve dress? (Wade) Aw, Dad,
You're embarrassing me!
(Bob) What? I- (Wade) Susan's right over there,
She's gonna hear you!
(Bob) I don't care what Susan thinks!
(Wade) You see the dress SHE'S wearing?
It's just duct tape over her nipples.
It's horrifying!
Ugh, it's in style, Dad!
Don't care what's in style.
No, n-
(Bob) We're gonna get you a long- (Wade) I'm not looking at the long dresses, Dad!
I'm gonna trip!
I've never worn a long dress with heels.
Bob: Women have worn long dresses for CENTURIES!
Women have worn long dresses and corsets and make-up-
Wade: I didn't think you were like this, Dad.
You let Mom wear those things that-
There's not much there goin' down to the floor, Dad.
I've seen it.
Bob: Yeah, well, I was married to your mom, and
she only cheated on me that ONE time
but otherwise it was cool.
*laughing from side*
Wade: it was your twin brother, Dad, you look the SAME.
Bob: She could tell the difference!
I've seen him naked, and THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
Wade: I want THIS DRESS, dad!
Do you know what Mom would say if she were here right now?
Imma let you know as soon as I find out.
Bob: I'll wait.
Wade: She said 'Instead of bats for baseball use a dildo.'
BECAUSE MOM'S A FREE SPIRIT, DAD!
And you're just stuck up and stuck in your old ways!
*bad feminine Bob impression* ~women should wear long dresses~
I don't think so!
I want THIS DRESS.
Or else I'M going to wear duct tape on my nipples too!
Bob: That doesn't-
Wade: We don't even worry about the bottom.
My vaginal region earth can just show!
Bob: I really don't like that you call 'it' that,
and that DOES sound like something your mother would say,
But, do you know what your grandmother said to me,
about your behavior, and the duct tape-
Wade: Grandma was crazy, dad!
Bob: -and the Miley Cyruses,
do you know what she said before she passed?
Wade: No, why don't you tell me?
Bob: She said, "My monkey swallowed on my car keys."
And I think we both know what she meant.
Wade: She wanted her monkey to be free too, Dad!
Bob: Have you seen the Kardashians? On the TV?
Wade: No, you wouldn't let me watch anything but golf.
Bob: Well, isn't that just peachy.
Wade: No, it's not, Dad.
I could be watching Fashion Weekly,
I could be watching the Kardashians,
I could be watching where to get nice dresses like this,
UNlike grandma's wedding gown you gave me at home,
which goes down to the floor and then some.
I'm not eight feet tall, dad, WHY is the dress that long?
Bob: Well, you're... you're goin' to prom so
you're probably a little bit young for the wedding dresses
for like a fully-grown woman--
Wade: D'you remember what Phil Mickelson said the last time he was on TV
the fffvvv... ONE good thing I got out of golf?
Bob: Ahh, Phil says lots of stuff.
Wade: He said to me...
well, he said to the screen which I felt like he was talking to me...
Bob: Uh huh.
Wade: 'potatoes have skin; I have skin!'
And you know what he meant by that?
I should show it.
In fact...
WHAT DO YOU THINK NOW, DAD!?
Bob: Good GOD! Just... come on!
Wade: Oh! OH! SO I CAN HAVE THE DRESS NOW! I CAN HAVE THE DRESS NOW, HUH DAD?
HOW 'BOUT NOW!?!
Bob: Would you just put...!
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
Wade: I just want this dress.
And now I'm wearing it.
Bob: Maybe you're not mature enough for prom.
Wade: *panting*
I think Security's looking at us dad, we should probably get this dress and go soon.
Bob: I think you should put YOUR clothes back on,
*mimes changing*
and we should go...
let me... I'm gonna deal with the security guard,
just put your clothes back on.
Sir...  Sir.
Uh...
"What's up my Cranky Crew..."
*audience bursts out laughing*
Mark and Tyler: End scene! End scene!
Ethan: NOOOOOO! NOT MY INTROOO!
*still laughing*
NO!
Mark: *mimicks* "Whazzup my Cranky Crew..."
Ethan: HORRIBLE SCENE!
Absolutely dreadful!
You're... going into battle...?
...in a war.
Mark: Alright.
* giggles*
Tyler: HUUUUAAAH
Mark: *Scottish? Davy Jones?* OAGHH, wrong person!
*Canadian?* ...Yep.
Tyler: Oagh?
Mark: Ohohoho *giggles*
Oagh.
Tyler: Oaugh.
Mark: Ahh, I know-
Tyler: *accent* I-I'm sorry.
Mark: The battle a-rage...
Mark: *back to normal* Y'know what, we should drop these fake accents that we were doin'.
Tyler: Okay.
Mark: We're not gonna fool the Scots.
Like, there's no way that they're gonna believe that we're like 'oagh.'
That's-that's just just racist probably.
Tyler: What're we doin,' Lieutenant?
Lieutenant Mark: Ahhhhh... I don't-call me Greg.
Maaan, I think we're close enough now!
Tyler: But...
I'm merely Private.
Lt. Greg-Mark: Ah, that's okay! Y'know, I-er...
went to...
law school or whatever the fuck it was-
Ethan: Change.
Mark: -ah, y'know, I... went to the moon a few times, I-
Mark: AH, y'know...
Ahhhhh IIII just ate a cat.
Real hungry.
Gaaaah, y'know-but I feel like, y'know, that brings people closer!
Pvt. Tyler: *whining* Why didn't you give me some of that cat?
Mark: Oh you want some? I still got some!
...this is the butt end.
It's alright though.
Tyler:  Thanks, I appreciate it Greg-
Ethan: Change!
Tyler: This is its face.
Ethan: Change.
Tyler: THIS ISN'T A CAT AT ALL!
Mark: Oh, well...
OH. Shit. Uhhhhh...
*mutters* is that somethin' else I ate around here?
Tyler: This looks like a horse testicle.
Ethan: Change.
Tyler: This looks like YOUR testicle.
Mark: Well, y'know...
Hey!
That's why I feel we're so close!
Tyler: why is your ball so big.
Mark: Well. I mean... I'm extremely manly?
Ethan: Change.
Mark: Ah, you know...
Cancer.
Ethan: *slight giggle* Change.
Mark: Uhhh.
Daiii's just...
I keep collecting 'em?
And I just add more--I've got a bunch.
Tyler: You know what? Instead of eating this...
Mark: Mhm.
Tyler: I'm gonna use this to rebel the Scots.
Mark: How?
Ethan: Change.
Tyler: I'm gonna... use this...
...as fire... wood.
Mark. Wow.
I--do... y'know, I, wh--it's...
I... feel like that's a waste of my testicles...
that I've been collecting for years now?
Tyler: I heard they're highly flammable.
Mark: C--from who!? Who told you that!?
Who said that testicles were flammable?
Tyler: Y-your wife said yours were.
Mark: I'M NOT MARRIED.
Ethan: Change.
Mark: AAAAAAAAAHHH
I'M ANGRY!!
Ethan: Change!
*aghast coughing noise*
Did you grab 'em? I coughed...
Should I turn my head?
Tyler: *dramatic* Greg.
Mark: ...no, you're Greg.
Tyler: ...I'm Greg?
Mark: ...yeah.
Tyler: GREAT SCOT! *both giggling*
I'm a Lieutenant!
Mark: Oh my God!
We're both Greg!
Tyler: We're both Greg!?
Mark: That's great!
I feel like we can even be closer friends
now that we know each other are Gregs!
Ethan: Change!
Mark: Oho man! *tiny giggle* You're my clone!
Mark: OHHH!
You're taller than me.
That's not cool, Greg.
That's not cool.
Ethan: Change.
Ohh man...
*grunts* I'm lost in your eyes...
*both giggling* Greg within a Greg... *starting to lose it*
Tyler: Is Greg inside me?
Mark: *holding back laughter* Not yet he's not...
NO.
Ethan: Change!
Mark: Yyyyyep.
*laughing*
*whispering* I can't do that. Not while there's war happening!
Ethan: Change!
Mark: Hoaghhh, y'know, it's... just...
...not the right hole.
Tyler: What, my bullet wound isn't good enough for ya?
Mark: *murmuring squeamishly* I don't wanna do that either!
Ethan: ~Change!
Tyler: My. Burn. Hole... from your... *various 'pfffts' offscreen* ...LASER...
...isn't big enough?
Mark: *incredulous* How did you get a hold of the experimental laser!?
Tyler: It was in your pocket. I just...
Ethan: Change!
Tyler: It was... attached when I cut off your testicle.
Mark: Damn it, I knew I shouldn't chain my lasers to my BALLS like that!
Ah, I keep losin' 'em that way! Oh well.
Well, you know what? I think we've forgotten the more important thing at hand:
We're about to die.
They're comin', screamin' their Scottish screams...
Tyler: Ah, that's alright, that's just Braveheart.
Ethan: Change!
Tyler: Ah, that's alright, they're just flashin' us with their butts.
Tyler: Uhh, it's...
...alright...
...they have nuclear bombs.
Ethan: Change.
Tyler: They're really far away.
Mark: You're right.
But their nuclear bombs...
*whispering* ...are really big.
Ethan: *laughing* Change!
Mark: But their kilts...
have grappling hooks!
*stifled giggles all around*
Tyler: That's... that's not important. What's important...
...is we're both Greg.
Mark: I feel like that's the least important thing-
Tyler: And we're gonna be the GREG WALL...
Mark: Wh-I don't--
Tyler: WE'LL BE THE BEST GREG WALL--
Ethan: *laughing* Change!
Tyler: we're gonna be... greg small...
Ethan: *breaking down* Ch-change...
Tyler: Or use our grenades.
Mark: Wha--again, grenade versus a nuke...
I'm outta testicles... *Tyler laughing*
I just ate the last cat...
The situation is grim. I was only trying to cheer you up
because we're obviously gonna die.
Ethan: Change.
Mark: I was only tryin' to do a dance...
*offscreen giggles*
GAHHHH I'm not good enough for that, that's why I always became a soldier.
My dad told me the same thing--
Tyler: But this war is won!
Mark: HOW!?
Tyler: It's won by dance.
Mark: Ow.
Well I don't understand how that correlates,
but my dad always told me that I couldn't dance.
Ethan: Change.
Mark: Well, you know, my mom...
when she DIED I was really sad...
Ethan: * giggles* Change...
Mark: Oh, he...
Oh man, my uncle touched me when I was a kid
...pushed me to be a soldier...
AHHH IT'S IMPOSSIBLE, YOU SPEAK IMPOSSIBLE DREAMS.
*whispering* I don't know who you are anymore, Greg.
Tyler: Have you not seen The Nutcracker?
Mark: No.
Tyler:  Oh.
Mark: Anyway... *everyone laughing*
Tyler: WE NEED TO WIN THIS WAR--
Mark: We do.
Tyler: --and it's through dance-fighting so we need to practice.
Mark: Again, I'm not 100% sure I'm on board with this,
but I'll give it a try.
*muffled giggling*
Tyler: Ready?
Mark: After you.
Ethan: Change.
Mark: Ohh, me first.
Ethan: Change! *laughter*
Mark: AAAAH I gotta STRETCHeeeeaah
before I danceeee.
Tyler: They say stretching isn't enough, you need to be massaged during the stretching process.
Mark: Ahh I'm okay.
Ethan: *high-pitched and giggly* Change!
Mark: You know what, that sounds pretty good.
Ethan: Change!
Mark: Ahh, but...
How many hands you got?
Ethan:  Change!
Mark: You mind if I make my own lotion?
*laughing*
Tyler: *reassuring* Let me get the testicle out of the fire.
Mark: Nyeh, it's pretty burnt right now.
The testicle I gave you-- cherished-ly gave you...
out of my collection.
Tyler: Well... I just heated it up for the lotion-making process.
Mark: How. How does that work?
We got nuclear Scotsmen,
we got grappling-hook loincloth-es,
I ate the last cat,
I CAN'T DANCE,
MY UNCLE TOUCHED ME,
THIS IS ALL GOIN' TO SHIT.
Ethan: ...change.
*Wade bursts out laughing*
Mark: *Southern accent* As mah grand-pappy used to tell me,
I love balls!
*everybody laughing *
*smacking lips*
Tyler: Scene ending, Jesus...
Mark: You are...
two construction workers... building the world's tallest building.
Tyler: Bobbo...
That doesn't go there.
Bob: You sayin' dis...
fuckin' huge I-beam
dat we jus'...
craned up here,
spent two hours linin' up,
doesn't go right next to dis fuckin' huge I-beam,
we just craned up here,
dat we spent two hours linin' up?
*Mark giggles*
Tyler: No, it's supposed to go--
Bob: You sayin' that was all wrong?
Tyler: It's supposed to go to the left.
Bob: It... the... fuck... its...!
EIGHTY FEET LONG, you see 'dis fuckin' thing!?
*Mark giggles*
Huh! What, am I just gonna scooch it to da left!?
Tyler: I thought that's why you took the steroids!
Bob: No, I took da steroids to get da chicks, okay?
*exasperated laughter* I can't fuckin' move--
Tyler:How are we gonna get chicks wit dose tiny balls and you can't move the frickin' I-beam?
Bob: We deal with that in da bedroom... they like da muscles.
I can tell you dis:
I was, last night, at the bar,
dis hottie, dis blonde, *kiss*
you know what she said ta me?
Tyler:  What.
Bob: I walked up, showed 'er da guns, she said...
'I want you to paint me like one of your dead neighbors.'
*background giggling*
An' I was like, shit! She knows who I am before I even talked to 'er!
Tyler: How does she know ya killed all your neighbors!?
Bob: I know, right!?
I'm buildin' a reputation!
Tyler: Ahhh... by the way, that serial-killer--
Bob: How da fuck am I s'posed to move dis big I-beam?
Tyler: Ugh...
Bob: Are you sure dis isn't right? This looks right.
Tyler: I, eh...
Bob: It's the corner of the whole building...
Tyler: Maybe it's upside down, can ya flip it over, at least?
Bob: Ohh, yeah, jus' flip it o--yeah, whaddaya FUCKIN' STUPID?
*Mark losing it*
Tyler: I'm sick o' this. You know what you used to say to me?
In these situations?
Bob: Not really.
Tyler: Instead of bein' mean?
You used to say:
'Cry like da baby you are.'
Bob: That sounds exactly like me!
Tyler: NO! *unintelligible arguing*
Bob: *mocking* Cry like da baby you are!
Ha-ha! Look, Imma do this weld, you just go fuck off
*laughter*
Tyler: You know, I could call the police, I know about all the neighbors.
Bob: You don't got any evidence o' that.
Tyler: *laughs* I got your neighbor's foot right heeyah!
Bob: ...Well dat's weird *background laughter* but I don't think dat's Jeff's foot!
Tyler: Dat's right, it's Johnny's, da neighbor on the left.
Bob: Ahh...
I--wait, that don't prove nothin', why do YOU have it?
Tyler: It's got your fingerprints all over it.
Bob: You--YOU musta killed him.
Tyler: I didn't kill 'em, your fingerprints are on it.
Bob: I ain't no psychopath...  I'm gonna call the cops right now, you know what?
You got dat guy's foot,
YOU cut da foot off.
You got da foot, I'm gonna call da cops and be like, 'hey cops,
once upon a time, a little boy was hit by a truck,
and dis fuckin' guy killed his neighbor!'
*everyone giggles*
Tyler: But...
...why ya talkin' 'bout Jimmy's son like that?
I-eeee...
I know he got hit by that truck, but he...
he ain't gonna tell on me!
Bob: He can't talk right no more but it's still funny.
*Mark laughing*
Look, I'm gonna do this well, and you just go cry like a baby'n fuck off.
Tyler: *sigh* Dammit.
Bob: You know what? You know what? I'll wait.
I'll just take a lil' nap, you go get the foreman, have fun goin' down forty stories.
Tyler: Instead o' doin' that,
I need you to do me a favah. (favor)
Bob: Prob'ly not.
Tyler: Yeah, you... you know, you said you were gonna do me dis favah like two weeks ago.
Bob: Sure.
Tyler: You can jingle mah bells
*laughing*
Wade: You are two pirates who just discovered the buried treasure you were digging up.
The treasure chest is empty.
Bob: Ahaar... this be it!
Mark: Yeah-- ah, sorry, ARRR, it be it!
Bob: Eh, you don't have to do the accent, I've talked about it--
Mark: GOD, thank you. God I was so tired of it.
Eight weeks of that on the sea?
You know, they make ships with turbines now...
Bob: Yeah okay, okay, this is the last fuckin' time we get interns, Jesus.
Mark: Alright, fine, alright.
Bob: Would... would you use the shovel and open the thing?
Mark: *sighs* Uuuugh yeah okay I'll use the shovel, fine, alright.
*making sound effects* PEEH, creak...
Bob: whuh...
is this thing a joke?
Mark: What!?
Bob: Is this one of those... 'goofs' you be doin'!?
Mark: Uh, NO, I have no idea what you're talkin' about, I'm not one to ~goof~ ya, bro.
Bob: I've seen....! I've seen the internet videos of the goofs, is this a goof?
Mark: NO, God no, I am not a prank YouTuber!
Bob: What've ya done with the gold!?
Mark: Jesus! I don't know! I JUST GOT HERE!
I think... I think there's somethin' written... in there...
Bob: Ohh, yeah, oh, okay.
Mark: Yeah, there's like an inscription on the bottom--
Bob: Uh huh.
Mark: Alright:
'I hear weed is hip with the kids these days.'
Bob: WHY in God's name would Blackscrote have put that in his treasure chest!?
Mark: Wh--I don't know, Blackscrote seems like kind of a dick.
Bob: No-- *grumbling* that the whole thing about his name is he had no dick!
Mark: OOOOHHHHHH.
Bob: I mean I guess he could have acted like a dick, I--
he's a historical figure, I didn't KNOW the guy.
Mark: ...are you Italian?
Bob: On my mom's side, I'm SORRY.
Mark: Oh. Alright, alright, I'm just confused about all the--
WHY DID I SIGN UP FOR THIS? I could have gone to Somalia!
I could've gone anywhere!
Bob: *indignant* Those be FAKE. PIRATES. Okay?
They call them ~Somali pirates~, they're fuckin' guys in fuckin' duck boats, takin' over oil tankers.
WE'RE pirates! WE be the pirates.
Mark: Well okay yeah, I know I...
but I mean, I went to four years of pirating school
and I was about to finish, I thought hey I could study abroad for one time in my goddamn life,
and this is what it comes down to?
Bob: I meant to ask you about that.
There's no way ya went to pirate school and they didn't teach ya the accent.
Mark: WHA--I...! Okay!
Bob: Where's your degre--where's your diploma, where's the scroll?
Mark: I'm not graduated yet!
Bob: Do you KNOW what they say about people who lie about goin' ta pirate school--
Mark: *groans* What.
Bob: 'Get that spaghetti OUT of yer mouth!'
Mark: Phbthhh.
*heavy dragged-out accent* FINE. You want ta hear about me piiirate schooool?
WHERE (phbthhh) sorry, still some left in there...
You want ta hear about my time...  at pirate school?
You'll discover me soon! KWWTCHHHH!
~I~ BE BLACKSCROTE!
Bob: Great Caesar's ghost!
Mark: That's not a very pirate-y thing ta say...
Bob: I be so shocked I CAN'T EVEN!
Mark: Yer Italian side is showin' true!
True as yer beard is blue!
Bob: Where's the gold, old Blackscrote?
Mark: Ohh, you would like ta know where the gold is?
Bob: Truly I would.
Mark: I'll whisper it in yer ear!
Bob: Uh, just say it out loud, maybe
Mark: Aaalright, fine, I spit a lot.
Bob: Yer pants are still down, too, it's concerning.
Mark: A'right...
Bob: How is it so black!?
Mark: It's an octopus garden in my pants.
*giggling*
It's down by Davy Jones' locker, it is!
Ye want yer treasure don'tcha?
Come'n get it!
Bob: *sighing depressed* How much gold is it?
Mark: Hoho, probably a lot!
Bob: No, like, concrete numbers
Mark: AHHH, it's hard te estimate when it's jigglin' around me scrote...
*stifled giggles*
Bob: You want me... to touch the blackscrote.
Answer me this!
WHO AM I!?
Mark: III--yee...you got me there, I don't fuckin' know...
Bob: THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT!
Mark: AHHH! MY SCROTE!!
Tyler: End scene.
*HYSTERICAL LAUGHTER *
The fact that you ended up with the 'octopus garden in my pants' on it...!
*CONTINUOUS LAUGHTER*
Mark: Okay, anyway, we're done here, so, uh...
yeah, that's it.
*giggle*
See ya.
Buh-bye. *bye guys!*